hello everyone and welcome to a most
exciting game from round six of the
grand chest towards your next move
rapid tournament in Leuven it's a game
between Fabiana Caruana and Shakti
Armand McGarrett and it's a very
exciting game because such a game could
probably never happen in classical time
format so it's it's good to sometimes
check out other formats as well it's a
really exciting game full of tactics and
I'm sure you'll love it
but before we get to that of course
there is a photo challenge and a lot of
you have been complaining that the photo
challenges are are simply too easy but
the problem is not in the photos the
problem is in your vest now as you
simply know too much but I have traveled
to the darkest corners of the internet
to find a photo that will be well I hope
it will be difficult for you to identify
but then again your knowledge is so vast
it's it's hard to say so let's check it
out who is this person and you are not
getting any hints in this one so here it
is who is this person
you all know him but you know that's the
only hint you're gonna get so best of
luck to everyone and we're gonna check
out the standings after we check out
this wonderful game so Bobby has the
white pieces and he opens with E 4 we
have E 5 and 9 f3 Knight to c6 Bishop to
b5 the reuleaux pieces on the board and
since this is a rapid tournament it's
very unlikely
mama Dara would go for something like
this in classical time control he goes
for g6 the fianchetto defense to the
rule Lopes we have c3 a6 attacking the
bishop brush up to a4 and now Bishop to
g7 the heading defense to d5 pawn d4 he
captures C captures and b5 now Bishop -
C - we have d6 d5 Knight to a5 we have
castles and already Knight to c4 so this
is definitely a position you will not
see in classical time format if if the
reuleaux piece is played the bishop is
on g7 that I didn't see for already
there is pressure on the b2 pawn so nice
the c3 preventing a knight or Bishop
from capturing on b2 Knight to e7 Bishop
to d3 and now Knight back to base
we have a four before now attacking the
night nice TV - and now a five
solidifying that point night e to D for
and here we have castles Bishop to g5
Bishop to d7 and Queen to c2 no you know
having more pressure on the c6 we're but
also if the F bone ever moves then nice
the c6 will also be an idea
and indeed f6 attacking the bishop on g5
Bishop to e3 and now f5 immediately and
Caruana does go 490 to e6
we have Bishop captures pawn captures
and now c5 and this this pawn is a like
a very nice bone in in Madhav's throat
but if I'm sheriff can defend and you
know maybe maybe go for some it moved
the night like Queenie seven and maybe
attack this pawn with a knife then it
will surely be a clean pawn up for
Mahmud yarv
rook a to d1 now comes f4 Bishop has to
move Bishop to c1 and Knight to c6 with
a Bishop to b5 attacking the knight
Knight to e5 and now it's not all that
simple to find the move here for example
if you capture then you get Bishop
captures and now this is a very nice
very nice structure for black after
Bishop to c6 attacking the rook rook to
c8 and now Bishop to d5 defending the
pawn and also threatening e7 black will
capture and afteri captures on d5 black
has this very nice c4 move and white
pawn structure is very nice but the
black's pawn structure and the Queen
side is a much nicer
so after this nice - if I move Bobby
doesn't capture rather he plays b3 stops
this c4 idea we have Queen to e7 now you
know stopping this pawn on e6 also
preparing maybe to capture of course not
immediately you don't you never want to
place your queen and king on the same
diagonal when this Bishop to c4 although
not possible now could become possible
so immediately Knight captures Bishop
captures and now Bishop to c6 attacking
the rook as in the previous variation
rub the c8 Bishop to d5 but now not
capturing the night as you don't have
that very nice c4 move as a follow-up
shocking to g7 simply getting out of the
bush up slide square diagonal rook F 2
e1 Queen to f6 and rook to d3 we have
rook to C 7 g 3 g5 and the Queen to e2
King to h8 now comes a rope to f3 and
Queen to h6 and now you can see that a
white is white pieces are really cramped
in it's very hard to find an active move
for white I have to play something like
King Queen to f1 maybe to prevent Queen
h3 and you don't want to allow rook F 6
rook h6 then you immediately allow black
to push this c4 and now black is already
better black is threatening to push c3
if you capture them Knight can capture
an a4 very unpleasant position for white
so after this Queen to h6 move Fabi
disregard some immediate threats on the
King side and he plays the Queen to be 5
with an attack on this night on b6 we
have Queen to h5 attacking the rook on
f3 rope to d3 and now Knight back to c8
we have rope to d2 here Fabi is
preparing Bishop to b2 to trade bishops
rope to g7 and now Bishop to b2 g4
Bishop captures on e5 and Queen captures
on b5 there are no tricks with something
like f3 because what can whiten either
defend immediately or or even or even
win the game we have Bishop captures on
g7 and after team captures Queen d7
White's attack will simply be much
faster eise evan is coming and after
rope moves Queen - Queen d6 threatening
checkmate and even after you stop this
and white captures now the threat of
checkmate will be dealt with by white
checkmate in black instead so
unfortunately no f3 ideas for Momiji RF
Queen captures on e5 Queen captures on
a5 grabbing a nice clean pawn on the
Queen side and now rope to g6
again f3 doesn't really do anything
because you simply don't have time for
this white can after f3 Bishop c4 and if
like you
thinks about something like this Bishop
to f1 will defend everything so after
Queen captures on a5 rock to g6 we have
Queen to a6 Rock to h6 now and Queen
back to D 3 bringing the Queen back to
the defense F capture Sun g3f capture
some g3 and now look to f3 Queen to a6 a
very nice move by Fabia attacking the
knight and CA and here my material has
to play nice Knights the e7 he has to
move the knight but the problem with
fabi's position is not the position
itself
Fabi is in a better position here but
the problem is he has like 10 or maybe
even less maybe 5 seconds on the clock
and you know he constantly has to make
moves and enjoy that time increment and
here mama plays rook captures on g3 with
check so he sacrifices the rook and with
only a couple of seconds on the clock
you can easily make a mistake here for
example if you play something like H
captures and g3 then you get Queen
captures with check roadblocks then
simply Queen captures you want Queen
blocks and now rook to h1 King has the
capture and then you lose the Queen and
the game on the other hand after rook
captures and g3 you could also make a
very nice mistake by playing King to f1
then black wins via rook to f6 check
roadblocks captures captures and Queen
to f4 will be winning after King moves
and now rook to c3 there is very little
defense against either Queen captures on
h2 or rope to C to both will be crushing
you can either allow you can even allow
a couple of checks here and after King
to h6 there's there are no more checks
and whatever move white mix doesn't
really matter
black will easily checkmate at the White
King so a very nice idea ruk to g3
it's not a good move but with a couple
of seconds on fabi's clock definitely
definitely worth a try
try so King to h1 Fabi defense correctly
we have 93 7 now mama Dara has to move
the knight and now Queen to a8 check
King moves and Queen to e8 or again with
only a couple of seconds on the clock
Fabi makes the absolute best move now
threatening to capture the night but
also Queen to have 7 check-in in
variations so Queen to f6 check are
preventing both only move for mama D are
off and here we have D 5 another
excellent move by Fabi of course you
have to react to this you have to
capture the pawn pawn is captured and
here here Fabi missed a very nice
opportunity here he played Bishop create
and Bishop trade seems like a rather
weird move to playing in a critical
position but I caught a glimpse of the
live coverage and Yasser and Janka were
joined by russian grandmaster and also
commentator for the russian coverage
again a mutiny chenko and his idea about
a bishop to 8th was that Fabi actually
wanted to play Bishop b4 but then he saw
that a rook to e3 wins immediately
because you will either capture and get
checkmated we are Queen to f1 or you
have to move the rook and then you
simply lose this Bishop on e4 so Fabi
already touched the bishop and then he
had to move it somewhere and he played
Bishop to 8 the problem is of course in
classical format Fabi would find that
this rook to f2 is beautiful for for
white the idea is now if you capture it
if Queen captures on f2 then you get
Queen captures on e7 King moves now
Bishop checks King moves and now Queen
to f7 with check Queen captures pawn
captures now you promote your
threatening to promote the pawn rook f6
but now H captures on g3 and with being
a piece up you're easily winning this
game
so after this rook to f2 there's no way
for it to actually capture the rook you
have to play rook captures on h2 now you
can't capture with the King because
Queen to h4 will be checkmate
but you have to play rogue captures on
h2 now you get a knight captures on d5
and after Queen to f7 check captures
captures and captures currently you are
two rooks against a knight and the rook
but the black has a lot of points but
the white can easily gobble up those
pawns simply rook captures the knight is
attacked after we figure this out and
then ro captures on h7 and everything is
well for white only one point in in in
compensation for the exchange that's no
real compensation so yeah in the
position a rope to have to definitely a
beautiful idea for Fabi but he probably
wanted to play Bishop three for like
likely began America Shengo said but he
played a bunch of to eight here comes a
for a very nice idea rook to e3 was
indeed the threat once again
but first mama DRF prepares it with
efore if or is the excellent move
because now the bishop is no longer
guarding the king and this diagonal so
Queen to f3 will definitely be an idea
also worship cannot capture the pawn
because of the same rook to e3 idea and
rook cannot capture of course because of
the same queen f1 checkmate idea
so here while panicking Fabi did play
rook to f2 but now rook to have two
doesn't work anymore because the bishops
diagonal is blocked here Mahmud are
simply played rook captures on h2 and
it's a forced checkmate so after rook
captures on h2 Fabi with only a second
or two on the clock
resigned the game and a very nice
victory for shahuri moment you're of
like I said it's it's it's nice to get
away from the classical time format from
time to time although in my opinion the
classical time form it is the real
format so yeah he resigned of course
because after King captures Queen h4 is
checkmate immediately and if you don't
capture with the King if you capture
with the rook then again it's no better
simply Queen f3 check this is the idea
behind the e4 move the bishop is no
longer protecting the king and this
diagonal so now you have to block and
that's simply Queen captures in G 2 this
will be checkmate so yeah after rook
captures on h2 Fabio signed and let's
check out the standings after the second
day in Leuven so these are the standings
and they don't be you know spooked out
by the score as these are double points
as they are scored for for the the
entire Grantchester
so in first place is still Wesley so who
had a who had an excellent day too so
far he won four games and drew two games
then in second place Levin areand and
Sergei kurakin Shakir mom
Yara of Maxima holographs Hikaru
Nakamura Alexander Grichuk Vishwanathan
Anand
unless you're in Fabiana Caruana anand
lost a very unfortunate game against
maxine by Sheila grout he had a
completely drawn end game and then he
made one weird rock move which was a
complete blunder and then Maxime of
course I took advantage of that
but yeah it was a very nice and I'm
really enjoying the live coverage by the
by the official commentators so you know
if you're if you have time you know I
like I always say that there are worse
ways to spend your time so that's it
as usual you can check to my previous
video Syria thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon
probably tomorrow morning with Game five
of the Carlson Island World Chess
Championship game so thank you all and
I'll see you soon